hello and welcome to las vegas not a
spanish happy hispanic heritage month
salutes natalia ill had we start
with celebrations for this
important month here in las vegas this saturday
september 18th you can celebrate the
hispanic heritage month festival
at game freedom  park from 10
in the morning until 6 in the afternoon
there you will be able to enjoy performances
by the folkloric ballet mexico alive
the sound dynamite food trucks
activities for children 1 come alive a
lot of things and much more for more
information call  at 70 25 96 99 12 and the
iconic barbie honors and celebrates
hispanic heritage month with two dolls
which they call role models to
islands you are looking at celia cruz and julia
álvarez as you know the queen
of salsa crossed paths with her  an iconic cuban-
american singer who he said left
a rather great impact on hispanic music even
after her death in 2003
while julia álvarez is a poet  This
Dominican American novelist and activist
is considered one of the
greatest Latina writers of the
times. It is important to note that these
Barbie dolls will not be for sale
and with the arrival of the
Hispanic Entertainment Heritage Month celebrations
by
Hispanic artists  continues to make itself felt here
in las vegas alejandro fernández celebrated
the cry this past september 15-16
with two concerts at the mgm grand arena
balbín that will be performing shows
within resorts world this
weekend at his new nightclub called suc
and mystery pipe se  coming up later
and into planet hollywood this
saturday while on the same day the
bronco group will be in mandalay bay for
a full list of concerts
coming to las vegas this
hispanic heritage month visit news now
dotcom
we continue to celebrate this special month
with  the presentation of a unique band
called metal h and which creates a
fusion of songs  s of rock with
really unique mariachi sounds and instruments
they were present at
container park this past friday but
if you couldn't see them don't worry
because they come to las vegas super
often to find their next show
who without being and visits metal to  chip
dotcom
good and this weekend life is
beautiful comes to downtown las vegas
again performances by various
artists like bill and jane and jake cortes
megan from star alliance impala and many
more will take place within 3 days keep
in mind that if you will attend  to this event
you must present proof of
vaccination a negative test carried out
with at least 72 hours if you decide to go to
one and present more no
negative detection test you can start the
process today
good until you reached your edition of
las vegas nao  in spanish don't forget
to visit snow dotcom in case you
need more information about these
events thank you very much for everything and
see you  s next week natalia greets you
bad sound
[Music]